hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i will be
showing you guys how to install and how
to use uh stack doclets in object dock
now if you guys i mean i i did an object
dock tutorial not too long ago and a lot
of people seem to like the the idea of a
dock for windows
and there is a rocket dock and an object
dock now if you haven't already heard of
stack doclets it's basically uh if you
haven't already seen this in mac os 10
being able to click on something and
have it spread and show what is
underneath it so i'm going to show you
how to install them and create them
so go ahead and open up a web browser
i'm going to use safari for this
tutorial just because of its download
speed
and now you're going to take the link in
the description and uh either click that
or whatever you want to do
and just open up that link and that will
be the link to downloading the file that
i've uploaded so you guys can uh so you
guys can just download this install it
straight away
so all you have to do is hit that
download button right there i'm going to
click it
and it's going to hit that's going to
say save or run you're going to hit run
and i'm just actually even though i
already have it i'm going to show you
guys how to do this anyway because
there's another step so go ahead and hit
run again
and if uac or user account control does
pop up just go ahead and hit allow or
accept or continue for anything it asks
so i'm just going to exit out of this
and it's going to say this is the last
part you need to remember
would you like to install this manually
and for what doc so i've decided to do
this tutorial for rocketdoc
for object dock excuse me you can also
click on rocket dock and hit install and
it would inject it right into the dock
for you so i'm hitting cancel because i
already have it
so once you already have this you can
just go up to your dock and uh right
click on any of the spaces you have hit
add
and you will see new stack 2.0 doclet
has been added to your list of entries
hit just click it
and right on the right hand side here
you'll see by default it says my
computer now i'm going to create one for
my documents so you guys can see how
this works
so right here my documents all you have
to do is click on this and then my
documents folder opens up but what if i
want to click on it and have my
documents all just spread out like in a
fan
well i just go ahead and right click on
it and go to doc entry properties and
this is the this is the customization
section basically for your stack
stocklit so we're going to change the
folder this is going to be the my
documents folder so just go ahead and
find that
there's documents hit okay
we're going to let stack documents
decide whether or not it wants to be a
fan or a grid it's basically
choosing that based on the number of
entries within the folder
then when you choose icon
i do plan on using uh i'm going to use
use icon as box overlay but i do plan on
uploading my uh my mac os 10 icons to
some sort of file sharing site and
making a video about it because a lot of
you guys have been really interested in
my icons so i'm just going to go ahead
and find
these icons real quick
mac os 10 icons
and i want to take a blue one
and it's going to be documents so that's
the icon that we use up here when we're
done and in advanced i don't really mess
around with these kinds of things these
um these are settings i don't really
play with when you hit ok you will see
the object has changed you go ahead and
click it and there are all your
documents so pretty awesome that you get
to do that and if you want to click on
one just just click on it and it opens
up
so now you'll notice this is actually a
blue icon on top of
that regular folder icon to fix that you
can actually go to doc entry properties
icon and just use icon as stack icon so
there's no overlay or overlap or
anything hit ok
and that works out perfectly so now you
guys can uh pretty much erase this my
documents folder because you can always
go through it right this and if you
always if you actually do need to look
in the my documents folder you can
always open folder using this shortcut
down here
and that is basically it guys so i hope
you enjoy your new object doc 2.0 stack
doclets if you have any questions about
this or how to do it with rocketdoc
which i also do have and use uh feel
free to message me or leave a comment
and that is basically it thank you for
watching guys peace
you